so where do you fall in on the Maga
Republican side of things well today I
think if you ask most people they'd be
like well Dinesh is in the mega wing and
I guess I am but I came out of the other
Wing in other words if you look at my
background I mean I'm not some guy who
like you know is a plumber right decide
to run for office I mean I came up to
the mainstream of the Republican Party
my mentor was a was a guy who was the
deputy to Bill Buckley at the National
Review my early articles were at
National Review I then went to work for
policy review which is a policy magazine
I went to the Reagan White House I
worked there for two years then I joined
the American Enterprise Institute the
think tank I was there for 10 years then
the Hoover institution in Stanford so
this couldn't be a more mainstream path
of the Republican establishment the only
difference is that after that and I
think actually my my case with the Obama
Administration you know I was at an
election
um you know I exceeded the campaign
Finance laws I was you know in a
confinement Center for eight months all
that experience
helped to sort of help me see a part of
America I hadn't seen before I think
that helped to shift my politics a
little bit is it also one last follow-up
is it also that if you are a republican
it's like you're a dead man walking if
you're on the Liz Cheney Camp the ASM
Adam kinzinger Kent the uh what's it do
to where's the eye patch to Dan Crenshaw
Dan crunch like if you're in that camp
like you're a dead man walking so it's
like either get on board with the Maga
train or you're gonna get run over so is
it like I'm not even saying about you
but do people just kind of have to be
opportunistic it's like yeah I kind of
have these principles but if I want to
win elections or get money or donations
or or even you know fulfill what my base
wants to hear I gotta get on board with
the Maga Camp well I think actually
that's
um I I'd like to Nuance that a little
bit because there's a huge difference
between let's say Liz Cheney on the one
side and then let's take Brian Kemp and
Dan Crenshaw so Dan Crenshaw is my
congressman
um and Dan Crenshaw won by 75 percent of
the vote he won the Primary easily uh
what state is this is in Texas this is
in Texas
yeah and he's running in Stacey Abrams
but he's leading by over 10 points yeah
again right so what I'm getting on here
and he entered into a big Skirmish with
Trump huge discouragement I mean the
whole Raphael Warnock and the situation
of the Senate was a disaster they lost
two Senate seats because of that
Skirmish that's right and I think
honestly there was a lot of blame to go
around by which I mean I think that the
the charges of election fraud were made
in an irresponsible way and many people
thought well if the whole process is
rigged why should I go vote and so in a
red State you have voters who don't vote
horrible that's what helped that outcome
to happen and then there was a Blame
Game to follow that who's responsible
for losing those Senate seats is it the
Brian Kemp establishment or is it Trump
and that that continued after a while so
here's what I'm getting at Liz Cheney
has basically become at least from the
view of most Republicans and operative
for the Democratic party she mainly
attacks Republicans she endorses
Democrats so she's in a whole different
she's basically become the face of the
January 6th commission and again look I
mean there are guys in January 6 who
should have not done what they did they
should not have broken those glass they
should not have they should not have
engaged in any skirmishes with the cops
but then there's a whole bunch of other
people who walk in there nobody stops
them the cops standing around they walk
in they're there for 10 minutes and now
they're in solitary confinement I mean
there's no excuse for that that that if
they were on the left that would never
have happened to them that's the key
point and that's really that's really
all we're saying about January 6th is
that there needs to be some Equity of
treatment so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here